the site of Israeli riot police
attacking Palestinians inside Al-Aqsa
mosque during Ramadan
has put Jerusalem and the Middle East on
edge again
Israeli police say several hundred men
illegally remained in the mosque after
prayers on Tuesday night and they
initially tried to negotiate with them
to leave
sits on top of Temple mount the holiest
site for Jews
[Music]
at this religious time of year many
Palestinians fear that extremist Jewish
groups will come and pray at the site as
part of a movement to slowly push
Muslims out of the compound
some of the worshipers refused to leave
they were armed with wooden clubs rocks
and fireworks and so the police went in
yeah
the clashes went on into the early hours
of the morning
in response Rockets were fired from the
Gaza Strip into Southern Israel most
were either intercepted or landed in
open ground one hit a factory but there
were no injuries
the Israeli military hit back striking
targets belonging to Hamas the militant
Group which controls Gaza
for a second year running the holy
Muslim month of Ramadan and the Jewish
Festival of Passover coincide
[Music]
it was always going to be a tense period
but especially after violence has been
escalating in the West Bank this year
Jordan as custodians of Al-Aqsa mosque
called for an emergency meeting of the
Arab League Israel says it doesn't want
an escalation that is ready if it
happens Alistair bunkel Sky News